[Music]
we are welcoming back to the program
today congressman ro khanna representing
california's 17th district
located uh in the heart of silicon
valley uh
always great to have you on david it's
always a pleasure
so what what's your big picture takeaway
of the november election joe biden won
the senate
is still a question mark it appears as
though democrats
lost a few seats in the house but will
still will still maintain an advantage
you could
i mean i can psych myself into thinking
the results are great
because it's so difficult to remove an
incumbent president and we should be
glad that we at least did that and so on
and at the same time absolutely
historically terrible reaction to
coronavirus
should have been an overwhelming
humiliating defeat for donald trump and
it was really pretty close in a few
states i don't know which side is the
right side
well that's probably true to both
obviously it's very hard to defeat an
incumbent
uh biden managed with all of
uh the help of everyone to flip five
states
uh that's the most important task but
there are certain warning lessons uh in
their one i don't think we had a
strong enough economic message that came
through exit polling showed that
of people who prioritize the economy uh
80 some percent uh voted for trump over
us now i've seen some statistics
would say that oh people who made uh
over a hundred thousand voted for
uh trump and those who made under a
hundred thousand
uh voted for us but that if you break
that down further you see that we do
very very well
uh with those making under a hundred
thousand who are
black or latino we do not do very well
uh with those are making hundred
thousand who are white and who are in
rural communities and in
communities left out and so the
challenge for the party is still how
do we have an economic message or a
aspirational message that reaches a lot
of these communities
because until we have house seats in all
of these districts and
at electoral college you're not going to
get progressive change on medicare for
all on
free public college and student debt
forgiveness very hard if you
don't win some of these areas is a
second
corona coronavirus stimulus bill
something that should be i mean it
obviously takes more than a day but
something that
joe biden has to start on on day one
yes i mean i'm hopeful that we can do
something now before we adjourn
the uh the idea i mean look here's what
i think mcconnell thinks he thinks the
economy will eventually
recover and there's sort of an
indifference to the suffering but there
is this suffering
that is going on i mean people are being
kicked out of their
houses of their apartments there don't
have in many cases enough food to eat
uh and this has already gone on too long
as you remember i was urging that we
come to some deal before the election
that would have been 1.8 1.9 trillion i
don't think that offer is even
going to be in the on the table anymore
but we've got to do something
uh and certainly if we don't have
something done by the time binding comes
that has to be his top priority you
mentioned
what you think mitch mcconnell is
thinking have any of your republican
colleagues who are
seeing this voter fraud narrative with
bogus lawsuits you know melting lawyers
and all of these different strange
things that we're seeing
have any of them leveled with you and
said listen publicly i'm supporting it
but i don't believe it and here's why i
want to stay in trump's good graces
or like do you have any insight into
what they're thinking
now you know the interesting thing is
that i have as you know relationships
with a number of the republicans that
trump has on for my bills we worked on
yemen but they will not even in
private uh criticize trump there's such
a fear
that that could get out that someone
could say something
that it could get back to trump so i
have never had a
republican colleague even in private on
the house side at least say
uh oh you know what we need to move on
they're they're very very careful
uh very careful what they put in text
very careful what they would say
to a to a colleague when this when the
topic is donald trump
so in terms of the joe biden cabinet
we're learning about more and more of
the picks
maybe one of the more controversial ones
is near a tandem for omb
we're going to talk about that tomorrow
we've seen janet yellen for treasury
which i think is actually very
interesting and she has some really
interesting economic
uh literature and history that she's
participated in over the last 30 years
which has been interesting to look at
the general idea of bernie sanders
elizabeth warren
leaving the senate to be part of the
cabinet aside from
specific positions strategically do you
like it
or not like it i think they they should
be part of the government at least one
of them should be just because
you know we forget that bernie sanders
won the first three states i mean i know
budape got the most delegates but he
got the most votes in iowa new hampshire
nevada he got millions of votes and so
to have that wing of the party
not represented uh i think is a a
mistake
uh it's a mistake for joe biden it's a
mistake in terms of the progressive
energy so
department of labor is actually a place
he would make a a big difference i
i would support that and it'll be a
challenge if they both are
uh shut out and my understanding is the
vermont governor is committed
to appointing an independent who would
uh caucus with
uh democrats i also think bernie sanders
has earned this i mean
if he wants to continue to to represent
folks in the senate that's his
prerogative but if he feels like he
wants to make an impact in the labor
department i don't see how with his
success and all he represents
uh why this is even a fight for him to
get this position
so if the position of the biden
transition team were simply
we can't afford to lose them in the
senate that would not satisfy you as an
explanation
no because uh bernie sanders wouldn't
give up the senate and he has clearly
gotten a commitment from the republican
governor that they will appoint an
independent there
who will caucus with the democrats so uh
if if they were going to be blunt
and said look we don't want bernie
sanders for x y z reason i actually
think that would be more honest
my view is that it would be a
mistake not to give bernie sanders
a platform where he thinks he can be
most impactful
bernie sanders thinks he can do that in
the department of labor uh he's earned
that uh
opportunity speaking of leaving the
senate i mean of course we have to
mention that in your state
uh kamala harris is going to be the vice
president of the united states and so
that will be a seat that opens
i've read a little bit about who the the
sort of
front runners are your name is being
mentioned by many progressives as
someone they would like to see
draft rokana call gavin newsom and say
is that is that a position that would be
interesting to you
sure anyone would be uh honored to to to
represent the state that in the senate
and it would give me a
probably a bigger platform to uh have an
impact on progressive
policies but i believe i can also be
very effective uh
from the house and uh you know the
leading candidate
appears to be padilla my bigger issue is
uh can we get someone who's progressive
was clearly for medicare for all was
clearly
uh for a 15 minimum wage free public
college and vocational education
for giving student loans uh and how do
we have bold policy and there are a
number of people who would
fit that bill but that to me is the most
important
yeah what's interesting i like that you
bring that up because i wanted to talk
about
what is the strategy even with a 50 50
senate with kamala harris as a tiebreak
boat
um there there are lots of democrats in
the senate
who are not on board with a lot of the
ideas you just talked about and and so
there's actually a real question i mean
things like medicare for all
and and many other ideas like it joe
manchin is not a guaranteed vote on a
lot of those things and when we could go
sort of down the list of some of the
more
centrist right-leaning uh democratic
senators
is that a concern to you and thinking
about the best-case scenario right now
would be 50-50 with kamala harris as the
tiebreaker
it seems to me that even in that
scenario there are real challenges in
getting some of some of the things we'd
like to see done
actually done david you're absolutely
right and this is where there's a
philosophical difference of
what way the bilingual administration
should go one theory of the case is
let's solve the pandemic get the vaccine
out
uh and then there's going to be some
natural recovery
to the economy and let's get whatever we
can get
in either a republican senate or a
divided senate where
everything has to get mansion's vote uh
i don't think that's sufficient i think
the
uh better strategy is to say here
is our vision we've got record income
inequality we've got people who've been
left out
we need to have massive public
investment in the creation of new jobs
we need to have
massive investment in child care and
education and health care
we're going to pass that in the house
we're going to build public support
we're going to make that case and even
if we're losing votes in the senate uh
eventually in 22 and 24 and 26 and 28
we're going to get that just society any
great leader in this country
has not overnight brought change they've
built public support we've seen what
bernie did
from 2016 to now so to surrender
the effort at building public support
because it's hard or the numbers aren't
there
i i think is an abdication of political
imagination and political leadership
yeah i mean speaking if we apply a
pragmatic filter to that for a moment
we could imagine a situation where
democrats don't have the senate
um and then the big things that joe
biden campaigned on
which are an expansion of obamacare
public option etc
pretty significant changes to the tax
code including uncapping social security
beyond 400k
stepped up basis elimination you know we
look at the full list of the really big
stuff
i'm hearing two things from from
different people on the left oh and we
just lost your video row i don't know
and you're back there you go that was
weird um so we're hearing two things
from people on the left and right
on the left rather some on the left are
saying you can't
comp these republicans in the senate
cannot be compromised with
what you would need to give up as joe
biden
if you don't have the senate to get any
of those things done
would um essentially degrade the quality
of the bill
where joe biden would be giving huge
concessions to the republican party that
are simply not worth doing
the other side is it's worth doing
in order to get anything at all but it
might end up being sort of a pyrrhic
victory do you have a strong feeling one
way or the other about how far
it's worth negotiating with people who
are often negotiating out of such bad
faith
well it depends on the context i mean if
it's a matter of getting some
unemployment assistance to people and
you're
you know where we can get 300 or 400
instead of 600
i say we probably have to compromise to
get the relief
if we're talking about expanding
medicare if we're talking about
free public college and we're talking
about student loan forgiveness and
there's really
something token that the republicans are
agreeing to but they're asking for
uh draconian cuts in other programs then
absolutely not
what i would say is let's pass in the
house let's pass
an advocate in the white house at least
biden's policies i mean let's at least
make sure
that that they're passing that i don't
see any justification for joe biden
and nancy pelosi not passing uh every
single thing that
he campaigned on i mean isn't that what
trump did i mean it did trump it was
wrong but
almost he went down his checklist here's
what i campaigned on here's what i'm
going to try to do so
fine and not to do the same thing we
have a democratic house there's no
reason why we shouldn't have every
single thing
that he campaigned on up for a vote and
if we lose the vote
let people know which democrats voted
against it let people know who voted
against the public option
who voted against medicare to 60 who
voted against
uh uncapping social security uh taxes
over
you know raising having taxes on over
400 000
who voted against raising capital gains
taxes
uh over a million dollars there are a
lot of policies
uh that we ought to vote on and my fear
is that they're going to say oh
let's have a lowest common denominator
where a mansion or
the moderate democrats aren't uh for it
that we're not going to have a vote and
and that's not going to fly especially
given that we have the house
last thing let's talk a little bit about
what's going on with the virus we
we fortunately appear to be just a
couple of weeks
from the first vaccines starting to the
first doses of the first vaccine
starting to get to people
december 8 to 10 there's going to be
this meeting to look at least at the
pfizer
emergency use authorization shortly
thereafter the moderna one
we're told within 24 to 48 hours of that
which could be december 11th
12th 13th the first doses are going to
start going into people's arms
there's two things that are sort of
going on here one is
the initially limited supply of these
vaccines where you can hopefully
best case inoculate 20 million people a
month
that's going to take a while before we
get to to some level of herd immunity
the other side is 40 percent of the
country still says they're not really
interested in getting a vaccine which
will make it very difficult to ever get
to that hurt immunity
what are you and your colleagues looking
at and thinking about in terms of the
vaccination program
yeah there was an interesting idea
actually by john delaney who sent it to
the op-ed to me that he says that we
ought to be linking a 1500
stimulus or payment to uh getting the
vaccine now i haven't looked at all the
constitutionality or ethics around it
uh but i think having some sort of
incentive system
uh to get uh vaccine uh adoption
should be on the table but at the very
least we need uh
massive funding on uh on outreach and
figuring out uh how we incentivize
hospitals uh
to get that get it distributed but i
think it is it's going to be a great a
challenge i mean i've
heard you got to get to about 60 70
percent uh vaccination
uh and and that's uh going to be the
administrative challenge now i will say
this about ron klein he's
uh exceedingly competent and whatever
else you think about
the ban administration i do think he
will
manage this process uh well yeah i mean
the crazy thing is initially none of
these vaccines will be given to children
and once you remove children from the
330 million population
you actually need close to a hundred
percent of adults to get to that seventy
percent and i don't think that that that
is necessarily being taken
taken seriously that's interesting i
didn't even i hadn't even thought about
that
uh point and uh it's a good point i mean
look they
they're this is where i think that the
binding administration is i mean they're
gonna be judged in the first six months
to nine months
on the administrative uh rollout of this
vaccine and i'm sure in the back of
their minds is that
when the affordable care act happened it
was botched the
the rollout and that really hurt uh
people and it hurt the
public perception so they're right to be
focused uh
on uh that administration but there's a
dual crisis there's that
problem and then there's an economic
crisis and then there's a structural
crisis that elizabeth warren and bernie
sanders spoke to
about in my view is we we can't ignore
both the structural crisis and the
immediate crisis economically
and we have to pay attention to that
substantively and for political reasons
do you like the idea of airlines concert
venues etc saying
after a certain date if you want to come
to an event or fly with us
you must be vaccinated yes i think that
that's a
a very reasonable position and uh and
and probably constitutional i mean my
sense is that you are required to have
vaccinations to go to school
for example so uh the uh
conditioning being in public places uh
it makes sense you know i was talking to
a
because i represent silicon nelly one of
the privileges i get to talk to some of
these leading
technologists and scientists and i was
talking to someone yesterday who said
that if we put the resources there's no
reason we couldn't have vaccine
detectors like smoke detectors which
could literally
detect almost any vaccine in a room uh
and we put so much money in our military
so that we could detect the smallest
threat to our country militarily i don't
understand why we're not putting in the
resources now to be detecting
uh pandemics and future pandemics that
is interesting that is not one i had
heard but i i will certainly uh look
into that
we've been speaking with congressman ro
khanna representing california's 17th
district
always a pleasure having you on david
thank you for having me a fan of your
shop